hey guys it is the 22nd of me today my
name is jeff mcdonald and you were
watching gamespot news HD versions of
Metro 2033 and metro last light are set
to land on pc ps4 and xbox one later
this summer and we've started to get
those GC resolution details a deep saw
the rep said the game will be 1080p on
ps4 and the resolution for Xbox one is
yet to be finalized before you go
worrying too much about that though both
versions are going to run at 60 frames
per second and the Deborah promising
updated visuals with advanced lighting
dynamic weather more detailed characters
with improved animation more dynamic
destruction and improved smoke fire and
particle effects the game will cost 25
bucks apiece or you can grab the Metro
Redux package with both titles and all
the DLC on any of the three platforms
for 50 bucks before any of us get our
hopes up for Fallout 4 or the Elder
Scrolls 6 Bethesda have said it's gonna
be a good while before we hear about
their next title marketing exec Pete
Hines said we simply want people to know
not to expect any kind of announcement
anytime soon I don't know for certain
when it would be the rumor mill that is
fallout 4 has been trying to link along
for a while now but it seems if it is
indeed in the books we won't be hearing
about it until at least next year some
new screenshots have been released from
the upcoming wii u game Hyrule warriors
to give you some sense of what the Zelda
dynasty Warriors mashup is gonna be like
there's a lot of them to roll through if
you're so inclined but information link
has epic blue eyes and smacks the hell
out of a horde of beasties link holds an
item above his head triumphantly after
opening a chest in baguettes her
unrealistically large sword fighting on
oh and groups Pickers video games lastly
the producer of soul calibur has
explained why soul carvalho sword is
single player only and it has to do with
its paid Irwin model producer Misaki
hoshino says originally we were thinking
about having a multiplayer option but
because we're going with a Peter win
model we were worried that by having
online multiplayer for all the new users
it would be coming in experiencing the
game for the first time they might be
immediately
deterred by fighting against opponents
who had superior equipment and gear and
we didn't want to have that kind of
negative impact on new players the main
reasons are opting toward free to play
for the dev was to engage the casual
market as well as old fans of the series
let me know whether you reckon a
fighting game can work without the
inclusion of multiplayer in that
commenting section below if you prefer
you can also chat to me on my twitter
where i'm at just mcdonald that is
everything that I got be today but
remember tomorrow I've got my top five
favorite stories of the whole week for
you so be sure to check back then I'll
see you soon